today we're continuing our study of
Friedrich Nietzsche's work for birth of
tragedy is his first major work and what
we're going to do today is go through
sections 5 through 10
trying to look at Nietzsche's
understanding of the development of
Greek art ultimately leading up to
tragedy not going all the way into late
tragedies so we're not going to actually
talk about your if it is today that's
going to be in the next lecture when we
talk about your rip ADIZ and Socrates
but the tragedy that's associated
primarily with Excellus and Sophocles
which were in Asia is sort of the high
point of Greek tragedies so how do we
get there in the last lecture we talked
about these these two different
responses to the situation or problem of
life one of these is called the D&S yet
the other is called the Apollonia
visioning they have two Greek gods GNSS
is the god of wine intoxication he was
associated with mystery religions
fertility cults losing oneself in a
communal tribal ecstatic experience
Apollo is the god associated with the
arts so particularly with the sculpture
the plastic arts as as they're called a
ninja you suppose okay these aren't the
only gods but this opposition is
particularly important so in the last
lecture we looked at that opposition for
saying it's going to come up
wotcher now we're more interested how do
these actually interact with each other
what is the interplay between them and I
have put into play in addition to
opposition because these are not simply
two opposed forces or responses or ways
of life or were descriptors they they
can be at the Antipodes for each other
but sometimes they can actually fuse
together and that's what Nietzsche
thinks is happening with this genre of
poetry then music and ours which is
called
tragedy so we want to look at how these
these two different forces as Nietzsche
has conceived of them they actually come
into contact with each other and don't
just provoke each other or push off of
each other but actually fuse into each
other we have to start with the reasons
for nature
why tragedy became what it was what it
was I say to not what it is because
nature doesn't think that there's some
sort of eternal essence of tragedy
floating around out there
he thinks that what counts as tragedy in
this full sense is something that's
actually in some ways a bit fragile you
get it sometimes and not at other times
we're thinking as well about how much of
this applies to the artistic products of
our long time or experiences you might
say not the experience of the artist per
se but the experience of the the
consumer the spectator the audience the
participant so we have to think about
the reasons for these opposition's for
artistic responses
gistic participation consumption yeah
here metaphysics and morals come
together if you remember in the last
lecture one of the points that I made
very early on was that for Nietzsche
aesthetics or the study of beauty art
you know what are these things morals
the study of what's right and wrong a
lot to be done what's the good life for
sorts of things and metaphysics the
study of what is ultimately real what
lies behind the appearances what are the
causes of things all of these come
together and try to dissociate these
from each other as is often done by a
lot of different philosophical schools
some of them just ignore some parts
altogether when they separate these into
different fields that have to be
hermetically you know maintained that
distances from each other so they don't
contaminate each other if you try to do
that each of things you're actually
falsifying another picture the ultimate
goal is to know reality and reality is
not something out there totally valued
neutral known without any sort of
effective or aesthetic response on our
part nor is it known just theoretically
speculatively abstracted it's known
through through thinking but it's also
known through living and it's known
you're living in contests in in
situations in lives that are strong
together well that's part of what drama
is going to
so let's see how we get there before we
do that let's talk about this
metaphysics that lies behind me just
project what is life for Nietzsche you
don't actually ask the question what is
reality without asking the question what
is life so you could conceive of a
cosmos totally devoid of life that would
be totally uninteresting for a teacher
he's interested in how does life adapt
itself
how does my assimilate things what sense
does it make out of the world in which
it lives its own once it becomes self
conscious its following place with
purpose or existence in the world and in
each other you know what I was thinking
in terms not some grand origin story you
know beginning with physics or cosmology
but what is life lived with other people
already in cultures that are imbued with
certain structures of the value seeing
things in certain ways what is life in
strident in responding to things in
taking on projects and seeing them
through yeah surviving in making do what
is what is life about so this is a very
basic philosophical question this is
part of my Nietzsche as a first name
philosopher because he's beginning from
the foundational issues is there
something behind appearances the I know
the phenomena behind all the things that
you could point to and describe one way
that Nietzsche wouldn't think of this
which we could
in our own time let's say you paid
somebody to follow you around with a
camera a video camera all the time you
know we have some shows kind of like
that
and we have some people who've done
projects kind of like that saying of
webcams of their apartments actually
making money off of that what would your
life be like is it all those little
moments put together those interactions
the things that people can observe or is
there some sort of other underlying
unity to your own life or let's just say
we expand and now imagine a sort of
cameras imagine that your mind is
actually taking all this data make sense
of it is there something beyond all this
data and information put together even
if we've organized system effects
is there something yeah he just says
yeah there there actually gives there's
something beneath the appearances that
we could become become conscious of yeah
he talks about this in section 17 which
we're actually not going to look at very
much today that I do want to for sure
passenger it talks about DNS AI art and
he says that it wishes to convince us of
the eternal delight of existence but it
insists that we look for this delight
not on the phenomena but behind them it
makes us realize that everything that is
generated must be prepared to face his
painful dissolution so that's part of
his massive that everything that exists
is one step away or several steps away
from falling into the void
nothingness it forces us to gaze into
what he calls the horror of individual
existence Nietzsche does think at least
at this point life does not have any
ultimate meaning in the sense of
something predating life or structuring
all life in each of you you will die I
will die and once we have died there is
no meaning or there is no you anymore
there are memories of us there are
traces of us
strictly speaking there's no Friedrich
Nietzsche anymore except what has been
externalized in his his books and his
thoughts you know Nietzsche is committed
to atheistic existentialism so the
horror of individual existence yet
without being turned to stone by the
vision for a brief moment he says we
become ourselves the primal beating and
we experience its insatiable hunger for
existence so this is very interesting
Nietzsche thinks that there is some sort
of cry about being greater than us
beyond what we are and we are in some
ways kind of extensions of this there is
a life that is greater than us not
necessarily some sort of platonic
conception of life or you know whether
Christians Jews wolves would you know
call God or anything like that but life
itself as what's going on is embodied in
this it's kind of a fairly Aristotelian
understanding of the concept but now
notice he does not committed to
something like a metaphysical moment ism
like you would find say in water
writings of Hindu philosophy
Benedict Spinoza instead what's at the
center of being
hunger conflict is what see a little
later on sort of a splitted jarrah
becoming another it almost sounds very
to Kelly over this point actually
Nisha accuses himself of being
dialectical what else does he say back
in Section age he talks about human
beings being separated from each other
and from nature so he says that
in fact all that separated man from man
human beings from each other gave way
before an overwhelming sense of unity
which led back into the heart of nature
that which would become alienated
estranged from the metaphysical solace
with which I wish to say it wants all
true tragedy senses away that despite
every phenomenal change life is at
bottom in destructively joyful and
powerful was expressed most cruelly in
the chorus of tragedy so there is this
metaphysical solace a consolation a
something saying it's okay it's not that
bad comforting right in the restoration
of the unity unity that's been lost
hearing AJ actually sounds like who he
sounds a lot like like we're selling
almost but he's not going where were so
it was either he's going his own
particular path so despite every
phenomenal change life is in
destructively joyful importance I mean
my life has been destructively joins
more powerful no but I can you might say
reunite myself with this primal life
that is later on he talks about desire
reaching beyond the transcendental world
not just the phenomenal but the
transcendental world
that's pretty interest he says now no
comfort any longer reveals desire
reaches beyond the transcendental rule
of values the world of so something
creates tractions right that which is
supposed to lie beyond the appearances
so if it goes desire go is even beyond
what lies beyond the appearances beyond
the gods themselves and existence
together with its gulling reflection of
gods and the world
is denied so this is a needles existence
any value to it whatsoever
is ultimately being said to to be wrong
even safety robot use because in the
circle maintenance and misconceive it
there's nothing there if you try to
reach beyond existence itself to find
meaning in it which is what our desire
prompts us to do you will find literally
nothing because there's nothing else
beyond existence beyond this and he says
the truth once seen man is everywhere
everywhere is aware everywhere of the
ghastly absurdity of existence that
ghastly absurdity existence is
meaningless senseless ultimately for
Friedrich Nietzsche
this is why he is seen as a nihilistic
philosopher although in large respect
Nietzsche's work is an attempt to
overcome realism but he stares it
straight in the face and it says yes
this is it we have existence
you can probe deeper into it if you want
to you will never find anything that
actually goes beyond existence even
though you can think of something like
that you can desire something like that
you can imagine something like that and
call it say God or the gods or truth
beauty anything you like any sort of
transcendental value but ultimately it's
all just here and this is it this is all
you get
so he thinks that that has a danger for
us so I put all these different quotes
on the board because these these capture
the two Sciences on the one hand you see
you talking about delight or joy you
know this is the sense of life itself
swelling up expanding its power
mastering things taking taking happiness
in that on the LPN he talks in in terms
of fear terror or asada speaks for
horror of individual existence the gas
they have certainty of existence he even
talks in terms of nausea invading a
person so this is the the substrate this
is the foundation of where Nietzsche is
is coming from now let's go back to this
is talk of the let's look at art
so
when he just thinking about grief ours
he talks a little bit about sculpture
the main things that he talks about are
that even more important at least in
terms of the relative space given music
is actually more important but in terms
of the space that gets to its poetry
speech so you know the park really in
terms of painting well the Greeks didn't
do painting they had in other other arts
as well dance it talks a little bit
about dance which is explored very much
these are really the big things now
notice too that quite often when we're
talking about the Fine Arts we separate
our drama as something distinct from
what we might call literature if you're
today taking a poetry class you're
generally going to take it on in an
English department aren't you whereas
drama would be in the theatre department
we separated this out into two different
things for the ancient Greeks drama is a
depth of a technical poetry you have
tragic poetry and you have comedic
poetry and then you also what we call
Satan plants which were basically
slapstick and a lot of jokes about
genitals you know things that you're
doing that sort of thing we don't
actually get much of that preserved so
we don't know enough about that sort of
stuff
the Greece didn't separate these things
out the way that we did and they also
didn't have all of them at exactly the
same time what did they hit first well
nature talks about two main poets and he
says that these are the two main
currents in the history of Greek verse
she says we may distinguish two main
currents in the history of Greek verse
according as language is used to imitate
the world of appearance or that of music
and then later on he heard earlier on
rather he says that homer classes are
colobus he says homer and arca locust
side by side as ancestors and torch
bearers of Greek poetry ancestors and
torch bearers so they are the ones that
are setting the pattern for everybody
coming after them but notice we doesn't
have it doesn't an s you walk in times
when we think of the Greeks we contrast
homer and you know somebody else who is
very important in
Greek thought because he gets wants a
lot of other people who seem to be
imported quite often say Plato Tessa who
also did a lot with but instead
Nietzsche focuses on Homer and market
locust why well because Homer is the
Lorien artist or X los and I can locust
is in certain sense the Dionysian artist
par excellence they're ideal types as
well as real people so what does he say
he talks about Homer and he calls him
someone similar to a sculptor
why well they're devoted to images the
sculptor contemplates in the in the work
that he creates the externalizes and
image a single image - maybe two images
together something like that
else Homer doesn't in inverse so he
creates characters the characters
interact with each other the characters
are identifiable apart from each other
each one has their own separate motives
their own history they interact with
each other but Telemachus is somebody
different from Odysseus who is somebody
different from the suitors who
Telemachus and Odysseus will later kill
the suitors who actually try to plan to
kill Telemachus Telemachus is different
than the thena who is taking on these
different guises and telling an aiding
him and hating his father Homer is
telling stories that lie on lots of
images what else do we can we say about
this well the the Homeric bar and then
you know it's worth keeping in mind -
Homer doesn't just stand for one person
Homer is the culmination a lot of
different bards this is what a lot of
classes think whose words are being
worked into a gigantic tapestry of
versed in the two main works and perhaps
even in some of the minor works there
well what do we know about about this
well Nietzsche talks about this in terms
of the Apollonia dream state
so again dreaming versus intoxication
and he describes us really well that
says this is the Apollonia dream state
in which the daylight world is veiled so
the world that were reused to imagine
people sitting around Homer was not
originally drafted was he was recited by
a rap so later on professional
interpreter originally the Iliad and the
Odyssey were spoken for saying that it's
kinda interesting too because in the
Odyssey you have this famous almost self
description of the bard singing in the
halls of Odysseus
things that Homer himself would write
about and you have discussions by the
different characters about the nature of
the bard and what they're up to and what
their value is that's a little bit
aggression but that also points to
something kind of important which is
within a dream state you can have dreams
within dreams and the dreams if you look
at the structure say the Odyssey you had
a story of being told within stories
sometimes within stories right Odysseus
is in the story and in the story he
recounts the story of his travels to the
people who are hosting him and they have
they have emotional responses to it that
his misfortunes all of this is within a
essentially a dream for us Homer is
introducing us to a dream and as well
that's quite different from our everyday
waking life sometimes people will read
Homer and other you know epic narratives
like that and they'll say wow the time
of the Greeks must have been really
something fantastic you know they
believed in all these gods and goddesses
and people were fighting each other and
you know doing these great speeches and
and all that sort of stuff there wasn't
the everyday reality of the Greeks
sometimes people replayed over there
that probably Greeks or some
philosophical they say around them is
fast all these sort of things all of the
pine they read this ability with a light
man I you know that sometimes they'll
say I wish I could have been back at the
time of the Greeks and just stand around
and drank wine and hate food and talked
about philosophy with people where they
sometimes they say holy crap I wouldn't
want to be at the time of the Greeks
they had to sit around and talk
philosophy and there was nothing to do
no TV you know well that was not the
everyday reality for the Greeks even
older was taking people out of there
and putting them into what niche is
calling the dream state in which that's
why light oil is veiled at a new world
clearer more comprehensive more
affecting than the first and at the same
time more shadow falls upon behind of a
changing shapes epic poetry epic
literature in general it doesn't just
mimic it creates now granted some of
this stuff is you know to us appears
kind of just silly imaginary you know
the dizziest has met land and the shores
of the lands of the Lotus meters we read
that sort of stuff from that you know I
mean we can try to do identifications
dabble in drug use of our time and it
seems a little you know for our but
that's not the point
epic poetry according to Nietzsche it's
not to try to create some sort of world
which that you know is perfectly
realistic and they all believe we lock
movies sometimes trying to do it's to
give us a world that like he said is
clearer more comprehensive more
effective than the first a world that
were invited to you might say escape it
what about the Unison artist he arkillo
kisses after the pianist he kept artists
products laws for Amiga and it talks
about the lyric poetry right he says he
is first and foremost a DNS yet artists
become wholly identified with the
original oneness its pain and
contradiction producing a replica
oneness as music if music may
legitimately seemly as a repetition the
world
however this music becomes visible to
them again through the ammonia dream
sequence there there is still some
Apollonian elements to him what is he
talking about
well Nietzsche talks about our Columbus
in particular representing a fast
emotions 2x about him as being involved
in efflorescence and music and images
and ideas images and ideas of look
images and ideas frantic love and
contempt for women
frantic love not just love frantic love
and at the very same time contempt for
the loved object contempt for the loved
person that that's remains inaccessible
passionate loves in the hates now you
can go passion of love into the Homer
right you know when Odysseus in the Sun
of killing the suitors
they hate those guys and though there's
reasons why they hate them yeah the
audience actually eats them too because
they're the bad guys they've been doing
some some terrible things and they be
told not to do it a number of times and
then they had treated Odysseus when he
was a beggar a very poorly as a visible
results right but it's not the same
thing to see the action happening at a
distance and for somebody else to be
saying I love I hate I feel I
I feel joy by night I am these these
emotions that's what the lyric poet does
I love this this particular phrase in
Egypt talks with her using seas he talks
about the entire chromatic scale of his
passions and appetites we're talking
about Archilochus
and the lyric garden the lyric poet Tara
chromatic scale what is the chromatic
scale you know we used seven tone scale
you know don't rainy Faso a lot too you
know or you know it's really in
different languages right that includes
full steps and half steps the chromatic
scale just goes it's a twelve tone scale
and it goes through the entire thing the
lyric guitarist represents in these
images very using their raw emotions now
Nietzsche he has a really interesting
digression here that I wanted to get out
very quickly and I want to spend a lot
of time on but it is important he talks
about people of his time and I think
there's a temptation in art wanting to
oppose somebody like Homer and then
somebody like arkillo ggest has the
objective artist to the subjective
artist the subject is talking about
himself and Nietzsche says something
really interesting here he says if
that's the case that's crap that's not
good
he doesn't say in those terms but I
think you know we could express her like
that he says the subjective artist is
simply the bad artist and you know I
mean if you've been in the art world or
if you have a son to other roommate
nephew niece who is going to be a great
artist a great musician
great poet many these sorts of things
and you look at a lot of their early
attempts at things they're far too
subjective and you know in a way I
disagree with engineer I think that
one's own interior subjectivity could in
fact be a good fertile ground for doing
good art but you have two people you'd
actually lived through some stuff some
eighteen year old kid I don't care how
much they have gone through their love
that's unrequited does not really have
the same pathos as it will when they're
40 years old
there is something the age does bring
bring death so the artist who's just
writing was just engaged and
self-expression just self-expression is
the bad artist he says we demand above
all and every genre range of our a
triumph over subjectivity
Nietzsche you know want one way frizzes
each would say something like I'm not
interested in your BS I don't want to
hear about you and your pain
individually as a single person I want
to know about the pain of the world what
it means to exist as a being in pain
I want something objective and not
objective in the sense of linking of
scientific objectivity standing back
from things there's a type of
objectivity here that's that's a little
bit different he says what does this
involve
deliverance from the self the silencing
of every personal will of designer
including the desire to express oneself
to think that one's going emotions are
somehow you know absolutely new the most
important thing in the world you know
you can step back from your own let's
say you know time are you that important
community we have these emotions they
exist they're almost like the beautiful
nose
just play the music don't insist that
everybody else say that it's the best
music in the world this song has never
ever been done before play the song well
it turns out to be the song that
somebody else has already done before
you can put your own spin on it but
don't put your own spin on it so much
that it's identified as being this
person's song play the song
Wow so that somebody else might actually
want to hear it so the Dean is to go
back to this now the Dean is the a clear
color what keeps them from just being
subjective Nietzsche thinks this has to
do with identifying with the original
oneness
now you know if we say that it sounds
kind of
new-agey can hippie-dippie kind of yeah
you know there's other ways of doing us
that aren't quite so so you know low
class intellectually there's there's a
long-standing tradition in eastern
literature particularly in hinduism you
know identifying myself with the
prideful one this as well great a great
amount of thought very sophisticated
thought has gone into that is nietzsche
meaning something like that
no it's producing here's word where the
key point is different Nietzsche says
that it's producing a replica out of
this one has to music how does musical
work do you play just one note all the
time and again we want to think of
Eastern mysticism or philosophy or
religion or something like that you
might actually compare this to a mantra
or to the one single no to the arm that
supposed to go through all of existence
Nietzsche doesn't see music that way
music is you know going all over the
list there's melodies there's there's
rhythms there's counterpoint White's
lady says the music produces an OP alone
in reflection in images and this image
reveals to the artist is oneness they
did the DNA see an artist identifies
with these images fuses with his
characters becomes the active center of
the world
so hatred or love or anger or fear or
whatever whatever effect were centering
or whatever imagine an effects were
century and then these situations that
are tied to them becomes identified with
this this primal oneness one of the
thing that's worth talking about before
a little bit further folksong he talks
about our kill Lucas as introduced from
folks on back into to poetry yeah a lot
of people tend to romanticize folk music
and in our day and a lot of people
tended to distrust local music and the
time of nature it's very interesting
because Nietzsche's Fox about folk music
as a classical instance of a union
between Apollonia and DNA siak
intentions so there's there's a there's
a uniting there of Papua and Indian sa
elements it's not just the initiatic he
says that the initiatic rules first and
that's through the melody there's a
melody first and then he started finding
words to fit and the words might be you
know about a feud or about a crime or
about loving somebody or about the milk
beats portal or whatever you like
provided you have a good melody for it
you have good music then we can start
finding images that actually work in
well with that and that's who become
fused together he talks about language
imitating the condition of music Dave
sparks about something that he calls a
musical mirror of the cosmos so what is
it what does he mean about that does he
mean that first the cosmos exists and
that music tries to find some ways to
replicate it
it's a sculpture or painting or things
like that - or does it mean that it gets
to something deeper so here we touch on
a really important idea for nature's
works not just this work but for other
ones we'll how does music actually
manifest itself
music manifests itself as will you says
using the turbine show content so not
just the will as a faculty that human
beings have you know like a con sense or
even Thomas or something like that will
as hunger striving motivation
determination underlying the cosmos
except that is to say the opposite of
the aesthetic contemplative on one
disposition for shove it up her to
appreciate art to appreciate is to adopt
an aesthetic attitude meant to disengage
one's own desires once all willing as
well striving all of that sort of stuff
that's actually that will show up that's
why show up in how her thought that art
could kind of save us existence so it
says at this point it becomes very
necessary to discriminate clearly
between essence of appearance it's
obviously impossible for music to
represent the essential nature of the
world music can't represent the
essential nature for it inmate of the
dancer from the realm of art altogether
stance on the will is the non aesthetic
element thrives knows rather than she
says we should say that music appears as
the will in order to express that
appearance through images the lyrical
poet must employ the whole rich
emotions from the whisper of love to the
roar of frenzy moved by the urge to talk
of music in the Apollonian and hopple
and similitudes he must first comprehend
the whole range of nature including
himself as the eternal source of
volition desire appetite so what's going
on the artist is actually expressing or
bringing to appearance not just
intellect not just perception but with
something that makes us most lumpy are
okay so all that said that's sets the
ground what is
what does the function nature says of
course if you read Greek tragedy you
notice that it's not like a lot of
contemporary plays where you just have
characters and dialogue do we have the
chorus characters and they're all on the
stage right we're used to thinking of
choruses in terms of churches and choral
words and performances and things
we're not used to thinking for Isis in
terms of a bunch of people involved but
not in a major way in the actual play
but that's the way Greek tragedy works
Greek comedy actually worked like that
as well
the chorus takes on different
appearances it's you know I had one of
Aristophanes classes a lot of frogs on
the frogs right the chorus made a bunch
of old mat as I believe if I remember
right it is in Bangka benetton but why
did you have something like that
Nietzsche says this is really important
to get down because if we want to think
about the origin of tragedy where did it
come from all the traditions tell us
that the beginning of tragedies was
actually with the chorus the characters
can't blame them they're introduced one
at a time and then you know to two
characters and a bunch of characters and
extras still a lot of the drama happens
block while camera doesn't were off the
stage reported in the discourse of the
chorus for the characters so what's
actually going up nature says there's
three misguided
and I think these are maybe still a
little bit comment probably the first
ones more fun
so why never course well one explanation
is it's an expression democracy you know
it's the populace against what because
the noble realm on the set of the
characters so the chorus ordinary people
and ordinary people are always smarter
than the characters who tend to get
themselves in trouble and bring about
terrible you know things that the
shocked and horrified you know sometimes
in use there's a comedy and tragedy
actually they produce different
reactions to us the poorest are the ones
who are saying oh wait wait don't do
that you're going too far with that
maybe that's representative democracy
another one is the chorus is the ideals
we'll get into that in a moment the
third which is particularly interesting
is that the court is in a living wall
so something that allows the maintenance
the willing suspension of disbelief so
let's look at this the the first one
Nietzsche says this interpretation was
also granted edifying certain
politicians but still the Democratic
opinions have represented in the popular
course of invariable moral law always
ranked the face and the passionate
misdeeds and extravagance of the Kings
may have been suggested by the phrase
Aristotle but this lofty notion can have
had no influence whatever on the
original formation of tragedy why where
tragedy come from did it come from
democratic politics or anything like
that not at all
it came from communal rights it came
from Greek religion it's purely
religious origins would exclude not only
in the opposition between the people
their rulers but any kind of political
or social context so that's not the work
that's sort of a modern anachronistic
way of mystery what's going on a Greek
tragedy what about the ideal or the idea
of the ideal spectator now Nietzsche
gets in a daze as many non Germans they
love anything that's that's called ideal
let's put that aside let's say maybe
there's something to this what would the
ideal spectator be it's it's the the
spectator that's needed in order to make
the work be a work of art and he says
we're in amazed when we compare our
familiar theater audience with the
tragic chorus in the haskers
the former could conceivably be
construed into something and now he has
to the lab why
well what would an ideal spectator look
like and ideal spectator with the first
of all sit up shut up right if you're a
spectator what what is it that people
hate movies right that's other people
commenting on the movie saying don't go
in there or you know making all sorts of
other commentary because if you're a
spectator if that's really a way to the
role is your job is to spectate to watch
to may learn but essentially to keep
from interfere with other people's
enjoyment like it says another thing we
suppose all along the spectator would
always have to remain conscious to
affect him for a work of art not
impurity reality if you're an ideal
spectator now this is a purely aesthetic
thing then you know that um before you
something which is not real rather than
reality itself does that make sense for
the Greek corpse no because the Greek
chorus actually reacts they are part of
the not necessarily part of the action
the part of the scene they're in it they
see what's going on with the characters
now they think that that is real stuff
so they say deal spectator think this
wouldn't work
what about the living wallet well
Lincoln says should we use this view as
his main weapon against contemplation
after the Schiller's the game comes
along against the illusionistic to be
animated
however while the datastage was conceded
to be artificial the architecture of the
sets the wallet the metrical discourse
stylized a larger misconception still
prevail Schiller was not content to have
what constitutes the very essence of
poetry merely tolerated his poetic
license he insisted that the
introduction the chorus was the decisive
step in which any naturalism at the
heart was welcomed the Chilean
naturalism of dark meaning art want to
take the everyday reality we see so you
know good props on stage that look
exactly like real things you see people
should talk like ordinary people and
people do in the world not in these sort
of artificial tongues that are common
especially trapped now me just says you
know as far as death being early death
long because again the chorus is not a
living wall in that sense he says the
world of tragedy is by no means a world
Harbhajan arbitrarily projected between
heaven and earth rather is the world he
having the same reality and credibility
as Olympus possess for the devout greed
is there a sense of which some of these
are true though this expression of
democracy
but these other two are actually without
a label and shoulder action there the
chorus is a certain way the ideal
spectator how does the chorus in a
certain way the ideal spectator well the
chorus is an ideal spectator not by
standing back not by being the perfect
spectator what by being involved the
chorus helps the audience in Greek
tragedy to become part of the spectacle
itself so that the division between
stage and seats disappears and everybody
is invited to become part or ssin the
drama that's taken place to feel to
react to be struck to learn to which one
happen
so the chorus is an ideal spectator but
ideal in a different way they're the
leading spectators they are also a
living law but they're not a living wall
Alicia says against the everyday reality
they're a living wall against the
reality that we were talking about
earlier existence itself being itself
life itself they allow a certain
constellation in part this is we're
going to come to the Apollonia portion
of this by helping by birthday the
images the Apollonia part images bound
up and characters to come to life so
that one doesn't just well the fact that
we're all going to die and none of its
going to have any meaning it does have a
meaning for this character in this place
or these characters together in this
place not in perfect universal meaning
that gives you a sense to everything no
one single tragedy is the whole of
existence or humanity at large but each
one is a sort of partial look into how
how life might look how what might
configure oneself in relation to that
so the chorus is the living law and this
happens to identification identification
with the characters who are an OP
ellonija element of the identification
artistic
Nietzsche says who is the character on
stage it is DN essence so in an
amendment Agamemnon is the initials
flight a pedestrian is dia missiles
against this is dia distance in a way
it's what I think of them now comes to
also is a blanket on her name the
Cassandra the slave from Troy who sees
what's going to happen
each one of them his DNS host each one
of the kid's life is reality embodied in
a particular form through metaphor
condensed so like he says what is Greek
tragedy the Greek tragedy is a DNS next
chorus which again and again discharges
itself in Apollonia images it says it's
an OP alluri embodiment of dns deaq
insights and powers he says that the
chorus is actually the matrix of the
tragedy the chorus is the substratum of
the tragedy the characters are kind of
floating on top of them that's a really
interesting way of reading Greek tragedy
I would like sometimes as a digression
but I would like some time to actually
sit down and go back through all these
Greek plays and just read the chorus of
arts and then just read the chorus and
the characters together and see the
characters as essentially responding to
the chorus rather than as drive the play
as we think they do when we read it we
often don't pay attention of course we
skip over that to get to what does that
a bit say what does that say
what does Medea say dear business was
not rid of passion the president merely
imagined
later an attempt is made to demonstrate
that God is real
figure together with the trans picture
frame vividly before the eyes of each
spectator this marks the beginning of
drama in the strict sense of the word it
then became the task of the dithyramb
the chorus so to excite the mood of the
listeners that when the tragic hero up
here they would behold not that
awkwardly masked man but a figure born
of their own rap division they would
their powers of imagination and vote but
only if they listen to the chorus only
if they allow the choruses lines to
penetrate into their souls and he's got
this great example from Greek tragedy
interesting enough for me from a tragedy
for somebody he didn't like her deputies
an agency I'll leave that from you to
them to look up a splitting takes place
between two different completely
separate spheres and the expression that
he says everything that rises to the
surface of the Apollonia portion of your
tragedy for the dialogue looks simple
transparent beautiful in this sense the
dialogue is a mirror of the Greek mind
whose nature manifests itself dance the
language of the sophoclean heroes
surprises us by its Apollonia
indeterminacy and lucidity it seems to
us that we can fathom in their innermost
being and we are somewhat surprised that
it's such a short way to go however once
we abstract from the character of the
hero has rights and services becomes
visible its appearance and instead
penetrated into this myth the story
which is projected in these luminous
reflections we come up against the
phenomenon which is the exact opposite
optical so what is he talking about
there what is going on in Tibet this
gets us to a really important point not
a tragedy but also Beach's approach to
life and it says if we look at Sophocles
and we look at nationalists Aeschylus
remembers coming before song this is
beginning the Sophocles is tracing
azimuth back
what is the one single character of play
of Sophocles that people remember the
most out of this and what had Oedipus -
well he killed his father son with his
mother that's why we have this complex
well no that's not all that happened
there Oedipus to begin with starts out
you know being being cursed by a
prophecy which leads to him having his
feet or ankles pierced and being cast
out to be killed by his father and
presumably mother being adopted
believing that that he's going to
actually escape the prophecy thinking
that these adoptive parents were the
real carrots coming back to his native
land which is being essentially besieged
and wasted by the Sphinx answering the
riddle of the Sphinx coming across his
father without recognizing him engaging
in battle with him killing him coming to
the city finding out that the king has
been killed and I realized that he's the
one who killed the king and as a very no
typical strong man marrying the Queen
and beginning children with her not
realizing that it's his own mother and
then you know launching doing the right
thing launching an investigation into
who actually killed
King only to find out that it was him
what doesn't need you getting out of
those like it says the sophoclean here
Oedipus is a problem of different ethics
different valuations
he says the profound poet tells us that
a man who is truly noble is incapable of
sin though every law every natural order
and type indeed the entire Canon of
ethics perish by his actions those very
actions will create a circle of hired
consequence it's able to found every
rule on the ruins of evil that's
essentially what Oedipus is trying to do
without realizing but it doesn't work
because reality is bigger and stronger
than any one single character no
character in Greek tragedy is able to
make the world become his subject to
take over everything what is a choas
tell us well you know one of the great
stories of vegetables is the story of
four medias
what does prometheus do he steals
firewood for Humanity and comes into
conflict with Zeus as there's a result
what does the Prometheus myth to
actually tell us he just says the
original philosophical problem poses at
once an insoluble conflict between the
man and the gods which lies like a huge
boulder the cave main ethnic culture
man's highest good must be bought with a
crime and paid for by the flood of grief
and suffering
defended divinities visit on the human
race innocent noble ambition he
contrasts this original crime with the
somatic event of the original fall right
a myth that he says exhibits curiosity
deception sucess and just ability can
Koopas us as a root of all evil what
distinguishes the Irian conception is an
exalted notion of active sin as the
properly Promethean Richard this notion
provides us with what he calls the
ethical substrata pessimistic tragic
tragedy
the tragedy of the heart of things the
contrary at the center of the universe
is seen by specialists of magneto as
interpenetration of several worlds as
for instance of divine in a human each
here's where it gets really interesting
each individually in the right but each
as it encroaches on the other having to
suffer for its individuality so yeah you
might say multiple ethics multiple
systems of right and wrong multiple laws
and all natural divine you know human
running into each other and here's where
the tragedy results they're all right
but they can't all be compatible and
they as somebody has to suffer probably
both sides suffer as a matter of fact
the individual in the course of his
aerobic striving towards university
allottee individuation comes up against
that primordial contradiction and learns
both to sin that's the active part and
to suffer that's the
this is at the center of the interplay
with the characters this is what the
chorus is whipping up the audience to be
able to to endure encounter through
their identification with the characters
the characters are not all expressing
the same point of view the characters
are coming into conflict and they're not
coming into conflict just as single
individuals they're coming into conflict
as representatives like you says these
these several worlds each individually
on the right but each has it encroaches
on the other happiness not for its
development this Nietzsche things is of
the essence of tragedy this is how the
chorus functions as a living wall
against the bits against the nihilistic
void of meaning to existence
it shows the conflict that's that's
occurring at the heart of things
particular complex this is how the
chorus is the ideal spectator this is
also why it cannot be an expression of
democracy because there's nothing crowd
like about this there is no idealistic
resolution of everything
and everybody getting to vote and
everybody getting along in Greek tragedy
now what would Street tragedy do it it's
actually a reworking Greek myth this
this way that prevents what he calls the
aquilonian sterilization one way to deal
with these you know separate worlds
coming into conflict and running into
each other and perusing each other you
know facing off maybe absorbing each
other would be to set up a bunch of you
know minds can you get this this area
you get this area you get this area you
get this area like what it's like the PD
articles do with the greed of meth also
you know
Neptune is the god of the sea Hades the
god of the underworld Zeus is the king
of the gods Hera is the queen and
goddess of motherhood and childbirth
debater is the gobs of brain and it
sounds like everything everything's got
it's a nice place well I had this sort
of problem ordered printed this guy over
here we got this from a problem over to
this but really the compartments get you
know they permeate each other they get
very messy and you see them coming into
conflict in classroom at each other if
you have like a perfect not an immediate
sense a perfect in other sense if you
had a perfect sort of systemization of
this everybody's got their place it
would be very sterile it would be a lot
of it as an ante life it would be dead
it wouldn't be real be like a mausoleum
meetcha thinks that this
became Homeric myth is is is transformed
through with your tragedy yeah the power
of music is keeping myth from just
rigidify again just it's an orthodoxy
into a kind of pretty history where I'm
going to be wrong here we've talked
about two important tragic playwrights
specialists and Sophocles Nietzsche's
going to end sections 10 by complaining
about something that that's happening
and is tying it in with a particular God
says what were you thinking of but we're
waiting your rip ADIZ when you hope to
press myth then enough last agony into
your service it died under your violent
hands but you could easily put its place
could easily put it as place an
imitation and would trick itself out in
the Masters Rose